today i'm announcing the public launch
of a new political force
the alba party he re-entered the stage
of force of darkness
technically and politically under my
leadership
seeking to build a super majority for
independence
what's clear is that alex salmond a
leader of the alba party
casts a shadow over his old party for
nicola sturgeon this is a friend
turned enemy turning the screw she was
on her election campaign trail on the
morning before the afternoon
that he launched his her nemesis is
getting nearer
an snp statement made its feelings clear
at this time of crisis it said
the interests of the country must come
first and should not be obscured by the
self-interest of someone
who shows no sign whatsoever of
reflecting on serious concerns about his
own conduct
concerns which to put it mildly raise
real questions about the appropriateness
of a return to public office is this a
one-shot deal
in a virtual news conference with old
and new media
hello mr salmon i'm from galicia what of
enduring concerns
surrounding alex almond can i can i put
it to you that
yes you were acquitted at your criminal
trial but everything we heard about
your behavior in government at hollywood
it scarcely provides an ideal platform
for you
to relaunch a bid
to re-enter public political life
after the two court cases the jury the
three inquiries
it is time to move on uh i wanted to
talk about the future of scotland for
the last three years now i've got the
opportunity thanks to the alba party
alex salmon talks about creating a super
majority
for independence in the scottish
parliament the hollywood vote on may the
six
is part proportional representation he
says he won't target the snp
in constituency seats but will target
so-called
regional list seats in the westminster
electoral system
obviously you just split the country up
into constituencies and whoever wins in
each constituency
ends up winning that seat but what that
means is that you can often end up in a
situation where you get parties that do
get
a chunk of the vote but don't end up
winning any seats in parliament
the scottish system tries to get around
that by using a system called the
additional member system
which means that there's top-up seats
that allow some of those smaller parties
to get representation in parliament the
way the vote works alex salmond will
likely have a significant effect
on smaller pro-independence parties like
the scottish greens
there are two pro-independence parties
in the scottish parliament the snp
and the greens between us there's a
majority for independence
after this election there will still
only be two pro-independence parties in
scottish parliament
the snp and the greens this is
a fringe movement this is one man on an
ego trip
what of the voting public we gauge the
view amongst
independent supporters i wouldn't back
him i think he's mad
i think he's just stirring things up i'm
not too sure i used to
he sort of worshipped him but these days
a
i think he's a big clever man i'm not
sure i trust him no i don't i wouldn't
vote for him for me it's
he's too much controversial and i would
prefer to vote for the s
p party it is the latest chapter in the
sturgeon salmon psychodrama
now a central theme in this hollywood
election
in the independence movement the plot
will thicken
as the fault line grows james matthews
sky news edinburgh